[Music]
there is one Disney printers missing
from wreck-it Ralph - we love any chance
we get to see our favorite Disney
Princesses on screen so when we spotted
them hanging out in the trailer for
Ralph breaks the Internet wreck-it Ralph
- we were over the moon excited well at
least until we noticed that some beloved
faces were seemingly missing in action
before we let you know who you won't be
seen in the wreck-it ralph sequel hit
the subscribe button for more from the
things if you're following the promos
for wreck-it Ralph - as closely as we
are you probably noticed this one here
we see some of our favorite princesses
surrounding vanellope but there seemed
to be some faces missing from the crowd
we see Jasmine Snow White's Cinderella
and Pocahontas just hanging out then
there is Belle Elsa Anna and even Moana
who is relatively new to the scene
finally we spot Rapunzel Tiana and
Aurora but there are so many more we
don't see naturally this left fans
wondering where the heck is Mulan in
terms of underrated Disney Princesses
many people consider the heroic Milan to
be on top of the list
she took her elderly father's place in
the army rode off to war and saved all
of China and after all that she doesn't
even get to appear in wreck-it Ralph -
alongside all of the other princesses
well put down the pitchforks because
this rumor is thankfully not true it's
been confirmed that her original voice
actor ming-na wen will be reprising her
role as Mulan she's confirmed that we
will have the privilege of seeing Mulan
on screen again and there will be some
hilarious banter between her and the
other princesses there are a few more
missing faces we can lay your fears to
rest about as well Merida from brave and
Ariel from The Little Mermaid are both
absent from this promo video which
seemed like a huge oversight however a
Disney representative has confirmed that
they will both be appearing in the movie
that's definitely her relief and we
can't wait to see these three incredible
ladies on the big screen many of us grew
up watching these Disney Princesses in
their respective movies and they have
had a huge impact on us we all have our
favorites for sure but we've also
wondered what it would be like if they
all met up one of the great things about
getting to see everyone in the second
wreckit-ralph is that we're getting to
hear their original voice actors
reprising their roles
according to Mandy Moore who voices
Rapunzel it was a thrill for all of the
women to be in the same room at the same
time Paige O'Hara who voices Bell is a
longtime friend of Jodi Benson who
voices Ariel but says that with everyone
else involved this recording session
definitely felt historic what is it
you're trying to say even the
notoriously sarcastic Sarah Silverman
who voices vanellope
admits that having all of the princesses
together seemed magical but despite all
the warm and fuzzy feelings about the
princesses getting together there are
some girls who weren't invited to the
party there are still some princesses
missing and we have some sad and
disappointing news about the rest of
them now one of our favorite female
Disney stars is almost criminally
underrated but then again so is the
movie in which we are introduced to her
of course we are talking about Disney's
Hercules here which contains a cast of
incredible and unique standards the film
was hit with viewers but its theatrical
release was a huge disappointment at the
box office in comparison to other Disney
films one of our favorite characters is
mogera better known as Meg unlike many
Disney Princesses especially the older
ones
she's completely over the concept of
love her last relationship went as badly
as it possibly could have so she's not
looking for a man when she runs into our
hero Hercules well you know how men are
I think no means yes and get lost means
take me on yours mega sarcastic witty
and clever and really stands apart
personality wise from many other Disney
characters there's no way we would ever
expect to see her being dressed by a
team of woodland creatures and for most
Disney women their relationship timeline
is pretty much spot prints get smooched
and fall in love but Meg's been in love
before and it ended with her being left
for someone else this makes her jaded
and she carries that into her
relationship with Hercules but this also
makes her much more relatable than most
princesses because who among us hasn't
done something foolish because we had
feelings for someone she's definitely a
unique heroine and she's from a movie
that Disney considers pretty
unsuccessful so sadly this means that
she's frequently blacklisted when it
comes to Disney characters in general
let alone the elite Disney Princesses it
seems like Disney has come a long way in
creating heroic non romance centric
storylines for female characters so
isn't it time we acknowledge that lag is
pretty much the best example of this
well apparently not because we will not
be getting the chance to see her in the
new wreckit-ralph movie in the realm of
underrated unsuccessful disney movies we
also have the film Atlantis here we see
another bold brash princess and this one
is a true warrior meet Utica cash Natak
the princess of the magical underwater
realm known as Atlantis most Disney
Princesses are teenagers but we know
that Keita is at least a hundred years
old and she's been around and seen a lot
of things in addition to having wisdom
and experience she's also a fantastic
warrior who definitely doesn't need a
man to rescue her she can fight she can
heal and she can save Atlantis and
ultimately ruled over it that's no small
list of accomplishments but apparently
it's not enough to earn her a place with
the rest of the princesses many people
praised the movie Atlantis for being a
huge departure from the Disney formula
especially when it was first released
even its art style makes it stand apart
from the crowd and it's been nominated
for a number of awards it is considered
to be a cult classic but it was never
the commercial success that Disney
wanted it to be people tend to forget
that Keita exists at all and we
definitely won't be seeing her in
wreck-it Ralph too so why did Disney
leave out Meagan Keita is it just
because they don't believe fans would be
excited to see them or is there a deeper
reason we know that these women
definitely stand out but maybe Disney
just doesn't think that they would fit
in with the rest of the princesses for
whatever reason or perhaps they're
powerful and spunky personalities would
overshadow that of the movie star
vanellope whatever the reason we have to
admit that we are more than a little sad
to know that we won't be seeing Keita or
mogera in this movie who is your
favorite Disney Princess and will they
be appearing in the new wreck-it Ralph
movie let us know in the comments
section and then click the subscribe
button to get more videos from the
things thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time
[Music]